good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight for
five full years through his campaign for
president into his term in the white
house
donald trump said often that he wanted
american troops to leave afghanistan
finally in his last months in office
trump seemed ready to act on this he
told aides
he was going to pull the troops out then
on june 26th of last year the new york
times
stopped him from doing that the times
were in a story saying that the american
intel community had quote concluded that
a russian military intelligence unit
secretly offered bounties to
taliban-linked militants
for killing coalition forces in
afghanistan
vladimir putin was murdering american
soldiers obviously there was no leaving
afghanistan now
anyone who suggested leaving afghanistan
would be bowing to vladimir putin
as a matter of principle american troops
had to stay in afghanistan and they did
stay they're still there today
official washington went berserk over
the new york times story
though the piece contained no actual
facts
cnn's senior intelligence correspondent
declared it
richly reported a rich tapestry of
reporting
and the rest of the media fervently
agreed with this the time story was
quote
independently confirmed by many other
outlets though no one
explained precisely how it was
independently confirmed
but they didn't need to because it was
definitely true we knew that the story
was real
the only question was why hadn't donald
trump
attacked russia in retaliation for the
killing of u.s soldiers
the white house has yet to authorize any
step in response the times gravely noted
suddenly it was clear
who donald trump was really working for
we need to look at the real threat to
u.s troops and the risk that russia
was putting a bounty on their heads no
matter what
memos may have been ignored what is the
truth of the matter here where do we
have to focus
to say nothing of putting bounties on
american troops
um it's unbelievable i mean he has still
yet to say
anything as the president united states
about
bounties on american troops do we really
have a president who on his fourth year
as the country's commander in chief
doesn't understand what intel is it's
all a theory
they're all leads until the explosions
go off until the bombs go off until the
attacks happen
i mean this says something really really
scary
about his fundamental lack of
understanding about what the
intelligence product
is and does how bad is it
donald trump doesn't even believe his
own intelligence
agencies that's the lady used to flack
for jeb bush and she was highly upset by
this that's
really scary she said the washington
post thought so
the post fact checker gave the president
four pinocchios and that's bad
for the crime of not believing blind
quotes in the new york times
the predictable rage avalanche followed
the daily beast declared it a scandal
and then adam schiff ranking member on
the house intelligence committee
reminded this country
that unnamed sources quoted in dishonest
left-wing newspapers are the quote
gold standard for what's true
he's inviting putin to washington uh all
you know while there is this um credible
allegation
of russians putting a bounty on american
heads that to me uh is just inexplicable
but this is not a hoax uh and the fact
that uh
the intelligence community is still
looking for additional evidence doesn't
make it a hoax
americans reading this are outraged
about what russia may be doing
that one person who isn't outraged is
donald trump it doesn't end up in the
presidential daily brief
if it's a hoax our intelligence
community not only doesn't put hoax as
it is present until daily brief
but rather it's the gold standard
so it doesn't wind up in the president's
daily brief it's a
hoax obviously it's not like we invaded
iraq or anything
we wish we could tell you it was just
democrats who were getting hysterical
but it wasn't
lying and neo-conservatism are
unfortunately bipartisan afflictions
ben sasse the sensitive tough guy
republican who represents the state of
nebraska in the senate
said that he wanted to see those
dastardly russian intelligence agents
quote
in body bags kill them kill them all
liz cheney of wyoming who by any measure
is twice the man ben
sass is demanded to know what the
president knew and when he knew it
what has been done in response to
protect our forces and holds putin
accountable
liz cheney asked the cable news shows
turned it up to 11.
the house foreign affairs committee held
hearings on it the new york times story
didn't simply cause political problems
for donald trump though it did
it changed the foreign policy of the
united states government
here's professional win bag seth moulton
who somehow got elected to congressman
massachusetts
telling you how important this is but
now we learn that
he was making this deal at the same time
as there were bounties on the heads
of american troops american sons and
daughters
we clearly need more oversight over what
the president is doing
in afghanistan seth moulton speaks
slowly because he thinks slowly
but he's clear on one thing we need more
oversight over
afghanistan and the congress soon got it
just days after the new york times story
both
democrats and republicans on the house
armed services committee
voted overwhelmingly to amend the annual
defense
budget they did this to prevent the
president any president from pulling
troops out of afghanistan that's the one
thing presidents aren't allowed to do
that amendment was sponsored by jason
crow he's a democrat
and by liz cheney who's a republican and
it passed the committee by a vote of 45
to 11.
it became law later in the year after
the senate overrode
donald trump's veto seems recall that's
the only
veto they overrode so
rarely has a news story had a swifter or
more profound
effect than this one did and by now of
course you have guessed the punch line
it was fake the new york time story was
a lie
it was placed in the paper by neocons in
order to subvert our democratic system
and it did
and once again imposed their will on the
country
the public didn't want to stay in
afghanistan for 20 years they did
and they got their way because they lied
the so-called
intel community is now admitting this
they're admitting that the story wasn't
true
and they're doing it for a very specific
reason joe biden has decided he now
wants
out of afghanistan but before we can
withdraw the troops
we need new facts you have to fix this
story or you can't pull the troops out
and the cia is happy to oblige
so none of it was real they can say that
now but what we can't do
is stop attacking russia so maybe russia
didn't actually put bounties on our
troops
but russia is still very bad russia
not china is our chief enemy and adam
schiff
helpfully reminded us of that yesterday
the intelligence community says that
they only have low to moderate
confidence
that it's an accurate story so it looks
as though in this case
trump might have had the right response
don't you think
well i don't think trump had the right
response in that he didn't confront
the russians on this he didn't even
appear to take the issue
very seriously you know it's my sense
that the intelligence community believes
that the russians
did engage in this conduct but they
don't have the requisite level of
confidence in that conclusion
to go forward with sanctions on that
basis
so donald trump didn't take the hoax
seriously enough
and that's a sign of bad character we
don't know the russians did anything
wrong
but we must confront russia over what we
don't know they did anyway
so attack russia every day if you don't
know why we're doing it
they'll know that's our new position
the bite administration just yesterday
declared a national emergency for no
obvious reason
joe biden announced that russia has
somehow taken malign
actions against u.s interests watch
today i've approved several steps
including expulsion of several
russian officials as a consequence of
their actions
i've also signed an executive order
authorizing new measures
including sanctions to address specific
harmful actions that russia has taken
against u.s interests i was clear with
president putin
that we could have gone further but i
chose not to do so
to be i chose to be proportionate russia
continues to interfere with our
democracy
i'm prepared to take further actions to
respond
save that tape for the future when you
want a reminder of
just how insane things got in the year
2021 that wasn't
posturing that wasn't their bad
those are actions against a sovereign
nation a foreign power expelling their
diplomats
destroying their economy threatening to
back their enemies
in a war a real war too not a war of
words a war where people get killed
we're doing all those things the
question is why
are we doing them that's the part that
nobody ever explains but they don't
really need to because
vladimir putin is so unbelievably
historically
monstrously evil you don't need a
justification to go to war against him
a man that bad should be punished just
for existing with nuclear weapons if
necessary
here's joe biden explaining that
vladimir putin has no
soul you said you know he doesn't have a
soul
i did say that to him yes and to and his
response was
we understand one another i wasn't being
a wise guy i was alone with him in his
office
that's how it came about it was when
president bush had said i've
looked in his eyes and saw a soul i said
looked in your eyes
and i don't think you have a soul and
looked back and he said we understand
each other so you know vladimir
putin you think he's a killer i do
and that's taking corn pop to a new
level you don't have a
soul you're a demon a human gargoyle
this is a head of state who has like
over a thousand nuclear weapons aimed at
us
why is our president talking about
russia this way
well it's obvious clearly moving toward
some kind of larger confrontation with
russia
why are we doing that and what will it
look like